It wouldn't be a mega makeover hour
without a mega makeover secret.
All right, our dream team member, Charlotte Tilbury
is backstage with some beauty tips, Charlotte!
(bright music)
Hi darling, Drew it's Charlotte Tilbury here.
I can't wait to share my beauty secrets with you.
So I'm gonna show you how to resize
and reshape your lips
to make them look really neutral
and universally flattering.
It's really important to get the right lip liner
and the lipstick that match.
(upbeat music)
Smile for me my darling, Angela, gorgeous!
You can really get the perfect lip pout.
So this will keep your lipstick perfectly in place
and it will set it.
It's a waterproof lip liner.
(upbeat music)
Now I'm gonna use Pillow Talk and Text.
Smile for me, darling.
(upbeat music)
So my darling, Angela,
what do you think?
It looks great, perfect.
Thank you.
Will you wear
that every day?
Every single day, I love this.
(air whooshes)
So darling, I'm gonna show you
how to get a Hollywood contour, literally in seconds
by using my airbrush bronzing powder,
underneath the jawline.
That lists the jawline.
Suck in your cheeks.
Follow the hollow underneath the cheek bones.
And then in a circle over the forehead.
And you go down the side of the nose,
down the side of the nose,
and then underneath.
(upbeat music)
Look in the mirror for me, my darling.
Wow, oh yeah, that's gorgeous.
You've got gorgeous cheek bones.
Thank you, now I do.
No, you do!
(Charlotte chuckles)
(Jen laughs)
Darling Drew, thank you so much.
Thank you, Drew.
(audience cheers)
And I am so grateful to Charlotte
to be able to say
that our audience is going home
with Charlotte's Magic Cream today.
Now this is every
(audience cheers)
Best of Beauty Awards winner.
You guys are literally going home
with one of the finest products on the planet.
Thank you, Charlotte.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪